The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, welcome back.
At the end of last
time, we said we'd
built up a pretty good arsenal
of optimal control tools.
Now, we're going to
start pushing them
in exciting directions, OK?
So many of you know I
work on walking robots.
It's one of my passions.
I think it's one of clear
unsolved problems in robotics,
right?
We have so many things we
can do with robotic arms.
Relatively, we
have almost nothing
that we can do with
walking robots.
Walking down the street
is still a challenge, OK?
So in my mind, one of the
essential problems in robotics,
it also happens to be the thing
that animals do just incredibly
well.
And even the really
dumb animals, you know,
locomote very, very, very well.
So some people might even argue
it's a predecessor to higher
cognitive function.
We'll see.
OK, so there's lots
of good reasons
why walking robots are tough.
There's mechanical
problems, of course.
Suddenly, if you're
a walking robot,
you have to start
carrying your actuators.
So you didn't have to do
that as a robotic arm.
And that's created lots
of interesting work
in actuator technologies.
How do you carry an actuator
that can produce torque
accurately, let's say?
If you have to carry
its own weight,
that's been a
challenging problem.
There's lots of
interesting work there.
But I will stand by.
I think that the reason we
don't have walking robots today
is not actuators.
It's not power density.
These are problems, but I
think the fundamental challenge
is in control.
OK.
And we are now well-suited
to make progress
on that control problem.
OK.
So based on what
we've learned so far,
walking robots
aren't that different
than the Acrobot
and the CartPole.
There's two things that
are different dynamically
speaking about a walking robot.
The first is we have to think
about limit cycles instead
of just trajectories.
And we're going to talk
for some time about that.
The first thing
was limit cycles.
The second thing is impacts.
Walking robots, every time
their feet hit the ground,
we have to start
dealing with impact.
So dealing with periodic
motions and dealing with impacts
are the two big
technical hurdles.
And they're not even
that big necessarily,
but they're the
technical hurdles
of taking the techniques
we've already developed
and applying them
to walking robots.
And impacts more
generally might be
called sort of hybrid
dynamics, where
you have a mixing of discrete
time and continuous time
dynamics.
OK.
So before I launch into some
of the models of walking, which
we'll get to pretty
quick, let's do
a toy example to start
thinking about limit cycles
and limit cycle stability.
OK.
So you can get your head
around limit cycle stability
with some very simple
oscillator type circuits.
My favorite simple oscillator
is the Van der Pol oscillator.
OK.
So it's a second order system.
These are the standard equations
for Van der Pol oscillator
where mu is some
parameter you can choose.
You can look at
it pretty quickly
and start thinking about it
almost like a very simple
spring mass damper system.
The only complicated
part is it's
got state dependent
nonlinear damping.
So think about it almost
like a spring mass system,
but it's got nonlinear damping,
state dependent damping.
And in particular,
if you look at it,
you can think of it as
having, if the magnitude of x
is less than 1, then is
that positive damping
or negative damping?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: There's a sign
change in the word damping
somewhere in there, too.
It's going to add energy to
the system if x is less than 1,
which I think is negative
damping typically.
And if x is greater than 1,
it's going to remove energy.
It's going to dissipate
energy, right?
So it's not too hard to believe
that you're going to end up
with something that oscillates.
If it's adding energy for
small x's and removing energy
for large X's.
It's not too surprising maybe
that you get this thing going.
And it starts oscillating.
I might as well show you
the real trajectories
instead of drawing them badly.
So if I do a phase
plot of this system,
which is two-dimensional--
it's got a walking
robot in the middle.
Sorry-- close figures.
There we go.
OK.
And yeah, that's good.
That's excellent.
OK.
So these are three plots,
the three trajectories
from three different
initial conditions, one
that started off with some large
negative initial conditions
in both theta and theta
dot-- or x and x dot, sorry.
And damping took the energy
out and started going
to this stable oscillation.
From another very
large trajectory,
it did roughly the
same thing, went
to that same basic oscillation.
And then even from very
small initial conditions
near the origin, it'll
swing out and start
going to these same
characteristic oscillation
in phase space.
So this is exactly
the picture you
want to have in your head of
a stable limit cycle behavior.
It's a periodic motion.
When I'm away from that
motion, I return to it, right?
This is exactly what
we want to capture
by saying a stable limit cycle.
It turns out it's not sort
of trivial to write down
what you mean by a stability
in the limit cycle context.
We'll see more about
that in a second.
But first, if you
just sort of-- let's
just use our imagine and talk
about some asymptotic stability
to this orbit.
Does anybody know
it from this system
whether this system
is globally stable?
Why is it not globally stable?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
I think it's true that
it's globally stable
except for a set of measures 0
is the way you say it, right?
Because, darn it, if
you start at the origin,
it's not going to get there.
It'll never start
moving from the origin.
Any other initial conditions
will find their way back
to that stable limit cycle.
So why is it not
trivial to say what
I mean by a stable limit cycle?
Well, let's plot
that same system
in the time domain,
same initial conditions.
Everything is the same.
Here we go.
Same exact trajectories,
you can see they all
go to their characteristic
oscillation pretty quickly,
in fact, right?
But you can see it's
crystal clear here
that the trajectories never
synchronize themselves in time.
And that's not too surprising.
So you're on the limit cycle.
If there's two trajectories that
are a different place in phase
on the limit cycle,
there's nothing that's
forcing them to come together.
So they'll continue
to be apart in time.
Such a simple thing,
but actually that
complicates our ability
to define stability.
We can't talk about trajectories
asymptotically converging
anymore because they don't.
They asymptotically
converge to some manifold,
but that's harder to describe.
As such, we actually have
relatively few good tools
for describing limit
cycle stability.
The standard tool--
well, actually
let me say a few things
more about limit cycle
before I tell you
the standard tool.
But there's actually a few
things that are interesting,
just good general knowledge,
about limit cycles.
It turns out, if you have a
closed region in state space,
meaning trajectories that
are inside this region
never leave this region, and
if that region of state space
has no fixed points, then
it's got a closed orbit.
There's got to be something.
It doesn't have to be
a stable limit cycle,
but it has to repeat itself.
If you stay inside
a region forever
and you don't go
to a fixed point,
then you have to
have a closed orbit.
That's the Poincaré
and Bendixon theorem.
And it's also
interesting to note that,
if you have a dynamical system
described by a potential
function, like any system that's
described by Lyapunov function,
that cannot have a limit cycle.
Anything that's uniformly
going down a gradient
can't have a limit
cycle dynamic.
So a lot of Lyapunov theory
doesn't apply directly.
And another thing is
that people don't always
call any closed
orbits-- these are just
random factoids about limit
cycle before we go on,
but they're good culture here.
But if you have a closed orbit
in state space, if it's stable,
people call it a limit cycle.
If it's unstable, people
call it a limit cycle.
If it's marginally stable,
people don't really
use the word limit cycle.
So for instance, on the undamped
pendulum, the marginally stable
orbits, there's no stability
properties on these.
People would typically not
use the word limit cycle
to describe those closed
orbits on the phase space.
But anything that has the sort
of converging or diverging
property around a
single trajectory--
so what's another
good way to say it?
There's some words that I liked
about the trajectories have
to be isolated in
space, basically.
If these closed orbits
are not isolated in space,
if there's not something sort
of separating between them,
then people don't use the word
limit cycle to describe it.
OK, so we can't talk about
asymptotic convergence
of trajectories on limit cycles.
We can't use vanilla
Lyapunov functions
to talk about stability
on limit cycles.
So what do people do, right?
There's a standard trick
that most people play.
And that's the idea of Poincaré
sections and Poincaré maps.
How many people have seen
Poincaré maps before?
OK.
Here's the idea.
So I've got some
orbit in state space.
This is XXed out of my
Van der Pol oscillator.
Instead of talking about
convergent to some orbit,
I'm going to define a particular
surface in this state space.
Let's say I define--
that's a bad choice.
I've got 40 colors here.
I had to pick the one
that was-- that's not
a very good choice either.
Green's got to
work for me, yeah?
They're all fairly toned down.
OK, let's pick a particular
section in state space.
Instead of talking
about the convergence
in this continuous
dynamics to this orbit,
let's just look at the
dynamics of that limit cycle
every time it
crosses this section.
OK.
This is called the
surface of section,
often referred to
as just some big S.
And a surface of
section, if it's
the case that all
trajectories that leave
the surface of
section eventually
return to the
surface of section--
I'm going to write this down--
then defining a
surface of section
allows you to convert the
continuous time stability
of a limit cycle into
the discrete time
stability of a fixed point.
So we know a lot about defining
stability for fixed points.
The big idea is we're going
to turn limit cycle stability
into fixed point stability.
And the name of the technique
is the Poincaré map technique,
let's say.
OK.
So I've got some continuous
dynamical system.
Let's make it simple.
Let's say there's no control to
speak of, no time dependence.
Let's just keep the
simplest sort of analysis.
I've got some continuous
time dynamical system.
Let me call tc the
time of crossing
the surface of section.
So I'll say tcn is n-th
crossing of S. That allows
me to define a discrete
time system, which
I'm going to call xp of n.
xp of n is x at tc of n.
I'm just trying to be very
careful about my notation.
I'm going to use p for any time
the vector x I'm talking about
lives on the Poincaré map.
I'm trying to be careful
about the transition
from continuous time
to discrete time.
And the result is a
discrete time map,
which I typically call
P for Poincaré map.
It can be linear or
non-linear, right?
In general, it's
non-linear for us.
Defining that surface of section
defines for me a map which
says, if I cross the
surface of section
at the n-th time at state
xp, then the next time
I cross it's going to
be xp n plus 1, right?
So if I'm on the Van
der Pol oscillator idea,
let's say xpn is something here.
I've defined my surface
of section, in this case,
to be the place
where x equals 0.
x dot is greater than 0 just to
define only half of that line
there.
It's a line segment.
This thing we saw is going
to go around like this.
It's going to get
a little closer
to the nominal trajectory.
It's going to come back here.
So this mapping is what
I'm capturing at p.
If I go around again,
I'll come here, yeah?
The key idea is
that, if that map
exists for all states for
any time on this map--
I go around, and I can
get back to the map--
then knowing that
you have stability
on this map that points in xp,
if xp as it evolves in time
goes to a fixed point,
then that must also
imply that you go
to a limit cycle
fixed point in
continuous domain.
Nothing else is
allowed to happen.
If I'm on this state in
my continuous time world,
then there's no time
dependent functions here.
There's no other state
that I'm not looking at.
If I'm on this
trajectory, I'm going
to stay on that trajectory.
Of course, a disturbance or
something could knock me off,
but we're just looking
at the nominal system.
So fixed point
stability on the map
implies limit cycle stability
in continuous time, OK?
Awesome.
Yeah, I don't really
need that yet.
If I work out the map for
the Van der Pol oscillator,
let me draw this map now
as xp at n-th step going
to xp at the n plus 1-th step.
At 0, it doesn't go anywhere.
So that's an easy point to draw.
I know it crosses 0.
I'm being a little loose here.
So what I really care about is,
since I know the position is 0,
really what I'm drawing is
sort of the velocity at that,
let me call it, xp dot.
Should I?
Well, xpn has two elements
the way I've defined it here.
Only one of them has anything
interesting going on.
I'm not going to write a dot on
top of my discrete time system
just because I don't
like that notation.
But I'm going to draw the
only interesting variable
of the two-dimensional
object xn.
If I look at my velocity
at the n-th crossing
going to the velocity of
the n plus 1 crossing,
it turns out, if it's in
here, I know from simulation
there that it gets
bigger every time.
Getting bigger on
this discrete map
means that it's greater
than the line of slope 1.
Let me draw the line
of slope 1 here.
On the Van der Pol
oscillator, it starts off
getting bigger, bigger, bigger.
And then at some
point, it crosses here
and goes off like this.
I think I can even tell
it to generate that,
so you believe me, Poincaré.
And I did it on top of
my other plot again.
So that's the Poincaré
map now of this system.
The blue line, this is
xpk versus xpk plus 1.
And that red line is
the line of slope 1.
This is a luxury of the sort of
low-dimensional systems here.
If I have a map from one
variable to another variable,
then just like the
flows on a line,
this is a discrete time map.
But I can actually analyze
everything graphically.
So what do I know?
I already told you by
writing that equation that,
if I look at my
Poincaré map there,
the place where it crosses the
line of slope 1 is a special
point.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Fixed point.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's
a fixed point, yeah.
I've actually got another fixed
point here at this, the origin.
Just by inspection,
I can tell you
about the stability
of that fixed point.
So when I'm over here,
I'm getting bigger.
When I'm over here,
I'm getting smaller.
So I can actually,
just by inspection,
tell you that that's going
to be a stable fixed point.
We have to be a little
careful about it.
I'm going to show you.
In fact, the right
way to think about it
is the staircase technique.
OK.
So if I want to follow the
dynamics of this iterated map,
how many people see
the staircase pictures?
Yeah.
OK, so let's say I
start in my system,
and xp is some
small number here.
And the right way
to think about that
is the next time I'm going
to go to this new value
I can sort of graphically
copy that down to my next xp
by drawing a line to
the line of slope 1.
And then I can, from
there, evaluate where
the next xp is going to be.
And now it goes right
into the fixed point.
That should have
been a little flatter
than I ended up making it.
And then on this
side, similarly, I
can got to here right
into the fixed point.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you kind of
emulate a flow diagram that
plotted xpn plus 1 minus xpn?
And then instead of
reaching the line of slope
of 1 when it crosses the--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Absolutely, sure.
Sure, you could subtract
out xpn from there
and get it in terms of 0s.
Yeah.
The thing that might be
misleading about that,
you have to be careful.
Because discrete time
systems can do something
that continuous time
systems can't do--
is they can jump, right?
So I could actually
define something
that then looked
a little benign,
but is actually unstable.
If I had something that looks
like this, what does that do?
You go here, here.
And you know, well, I
guess it goes down to here.
That one might actually catch--
shoot, I didn't make my point.
You could limit cycle here
like this or something, right?
I did a more dramatic
plot to make my point.
It's pretty funny that
it's all unitless.
So the fact that I gave myself
that problem is ridiculous.
You can imagine starting
off here, getting
bigger and bigger,
and off you go, right?
OK, so what are the conditions
for stability, local stability
on that fixed point?
You all know what they
are, but just now you
can maybe see them graphically
by my exaggerated example.
What are the conditions
on the local stability?
What does the slope of
that line have to be?
AUDIENCE: It has
to be less than 1?
RUSS TEDRAKE: The magnitude
has to be less than 1, right?
It could be sloped like
this, sloped like this.
What matters is that it's
not sloped past the line.
The other, the simpler thing,
to draw for instability
would be if my plot had
gone like this, that it's
clearly unstable, right?
Because then I'd go
like this, this, this.
Then off I go to infinity.
But it also happens if
I'm unstable like this
because I oscillate
myself off to infinity.
If I look at the gradient
of p with respect
to x at some fixed point,
the eigenvalues of that
had better be less than
1 for it to be stable.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if
you're linearized,
then you're basically
at that point.
RUSS TEDRAKE: So
that's a statement
about local stability.
One of the cool things
about these maps,
actually, is people
have stronger--
certainly, graphically I did
sort of a stronger thing.
I said I could just look at this
and know that it was stable.
People actually know quite
a bit about the properties
of these maps.
Just again for
culture, it turns out,
if you have a unimodal
map like this,
if the gradient
doesn't change same
and if it's locally stable, then
you can infer global stability.
There's a citation in
the notes where you can
see the careful result of that.
Some of the Koditschek's hopping
work exploited that result.
So people do know some things,
more strong global properties
of these maps.
But the trivial one to think
about is this local stability.
OK, so we know a
bit now about how
to talk about whether a
limit cycle system is stable.
It's a little more subtle
than fixed point stability,
but not too bad.
The hard part comes if you can't
find a mapping where it always
returns to itself.
And then you have
problems, right?
But in this case, you
can say strong things
about the stability.
OK.
Now, we're set up to talk about
walking, so my favorite topic
here.
Let me actually
say historically,
I mean, people
have obviously been
interested in walking
for a long, long time.
Some people say
that the first sort
of serious study of
legged locomotion
was by a photographer.
What's his name?
AUDIENCE: Muybridge.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Muybridge, good.
Yeah.
So a photographer had a sort
of a fast shutter speed camera.
And he had animals run in front
of graph paper, basically.
And he tried to win a bet,
I think, was the story.
Because people
weren't sure, when
horses were doing their sort
of certain gait, whether they--
I think it was a gallop.
They asked, when the
horse gallops does,
he ever actually get all
four feet off the ground?
And the guy who
sort of proved that
was a photographer, that took a
picture of all four feet coming
off the ground.
And you can get his books,
which are these fantastic
books of all sorts of
animals, just pictures
and pictures and pictures of
all sorts of animals, sort
of almost stroke photography
of these animals walking
in front of graph paper.
You get elephants, and camels,
and humans, and babies,
and horses, and dogs.
You name it.
So if you ever
sort of are curious
what the gate of a
certain animal looks like,
you can go to Muybridge.
And he also sort of started
defining this language
for describing the gaits
of different animals,
like which feet are on
the ground at which time
and stuff like that.
So this was in the
turn of the century,
the late 1800s, early 1900s.
This photographer sort
of started our field.
More recently,
though, the first sort
of serious modeling,
which is the impact that
sort of remained today, I
think, was McMahon at Harvard.
He was a biomechanicist.
And he observed that
EMG in your leg,
if you look at the
muscle activity,
Electromyographic
activity in your leg,
so just the electrical
signal sent to your muscle,
that your stance leg
has very little EMG--
sorry, a lot of EMG.
And your swing has
very little EMG
with the exception of,
right when you begin swing,
there's a lot of EMG.
And right towards
the end of swing,
there's a lot of EMG activity.
So your muscles are doing
seemingly a lot of work
at the beginning and
end, and your stance leg
is doing a lot of work.
But the surprising thing
was that inside of phase
your muscles almost turn off.
So McMahon produced for the
world the ballistic walker
model.
He was at Harvard.
And he basically
did some modeling
of a three-link pendulum,
something like that
and showed that, even with a
straight leg on your stance
leg, if you let your
swing leg just go,
that you can get very
natural gaits coming out,
very reasonable kinematic
descriptions of what
human walking looks like, hence
the name ballistic walker.
This is a passive phase.
So one of the dominant ideas
that came out of that work
was the sort of notion
that people talk about now
as walking by vaulting.
If you want a first
order approximation
of what walking is, they said
think about your stance leg
as a rod.
And you just vault
over your stance leg.
And in fact, peoples'
center of mass
do tend to go up over the course
of a stance and then back down.
So the dominant
theory really was
that you could think
about this as a stiff leg
and then an almost
passive swing phase.
Now, I remember last year's
dynamic walking meeting.
Basically, half the
talks were saying walking
is not vaulting anymore.
It's just in the last year
or so people are really,
really changing their mind
about this, including you
guys in Media Lab
are talking a lot
about the role of compliance
in the stance leg in energy
storage during walking,
which was left out
of these initial models.
But I think, if
you want a 0 order
model of walking, thinking
about your stance leg
as straight is not
a bad way to start.
And the other thing that
happened because of this work
was this idea of
passive dynamic walking.
So this guy Tad McGeer--
so McMahon's model was just
a model of the swing phase.
It didn't talk about stability.
It didn't even talk
about ground contact.
It wasn't sort of
a periodic motion.
It was saying something about
the kinematics of swing phase.
And this guy Tad McGeer, who's
actually an aeroengineer,
he works on UADs now, came in
and turned the robotics world
on its head by building
a bunch of machines
that had no motor,
no controller,
and walked down a small
ramp basically using
these ballistic
walking kind of ideas.
So Tad's a good guy.
Let him describe.
I've got a video of him talking
about passive walking here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This familiar toy is a
passive dynamic walker.
[INAUDIBLE] all the way.
And right at the start, it
settles into a steady walking
cycle sustained by an entirely
passive interaction of gravity
and inertia.
This machine is also a
passive dynamic walker.
For that matter, I may be
a passive dynamic walker.
As you'll see, our
gaits are quite similar.
[INAUDIBLE] with the analysis,
and by intuition [INAUDIBLE]
exclusively [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
God.
Once you establish [INAUDIBLE],,
the reason the machine failed
was a problem
called [INAUDIBLE]..
So for later
experiments, we went
to a set of mechanical patches.
And the next sequence shows
our first trial with those.
I guess that worked.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's a big deal.
That started a lot of research.
AUDIENCE: Is that 1990?
RUSS TEDRAKE: 1990, exactly.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This familiar toy--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Whoops, sorry.
- [INAUDIBLE] today is that
we have all four debouncers
[INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: The knee
latches the last time
are the debouncers of today.
- [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: No
motor, no controller,
that's just falling down a ramp.
That's beautiful.
I love this video,
because it shows
you sort of the honest
capabilities of these things.
There's a few outtakes.
[LAUGHTER]
That's what it's like
working with them.
That was pretty benign.
It's a pretty robust
phenomenon, right?
So this is--
[LAUGHTER]
--he's changing the
ramp angle quite a bit
and getting these really
graceful motions out.
This guy walks sideways
for some reason.
It's really good, yeah?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
You got to realize
this was at a time
when the walking robots of the
world were going like this,
moving like that.
This guy says, I got a robot
with no motor, no controller.
Look what it can do, yeah?
Really amazing-- and he was an
aerospace engineer, go figure.
This is stealing the show.
That's the next bit.
So these passive walking ideas
have really had a big impact
on the world of walking robots.
They had it in two
waves, I guess.
Everybody knew that a
purely passive walker
could walk down a small slope.
And then people have
been working for--
the second part of
that video was a video.
Finally, someone
had put motors on it
to make it walk on the flat
because it took a surprisingly
long time to make that leap.
So now, people, I
think, don't just
think they're a
nice party trick,
but they actually may be useful
for designer of real walking
machines.
AUDIENCE: Why [INAUDIBLE]?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Well,
because they don't know
how to underactuate a control.
I think, quite honestly,
that's my answer.
Yeah.
We don't have any
good control ideas.
I mean, what you want
to do here is just push
a little bit of energy into
the system in the right way.
We don't know how to formulate
those control problems when
the systems are so
non-linear and discontinuous
and everything.
Plus, I think the
people that are
good at building
those things maybe
are not the same people
that are going at control.
It takes a special talent
to turn enough screws.
So you should know that the way
that the knee stayed attached--
how do you think the knee
state attached in that?
Why did the knee not bend
during the stance phase?
AUDIENCE: Magnetic or something?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It wasn't
magnetic, but that's close.
You can imagine, maybe, the
curvature of the foot doing it,
but that's not it.
They're suction cups, yeah?
It goes.
And the suction cups
don't just stick.
You poke a hole in the
back of the suction cup.
And you tune the leakage
of the suction, right?
So that at the right time, it
pops off and goes like this.
This is not for
the weak of heart.
There's a lot of tuning
that goes into these things.
So our most dramatic
failure, I think,
was we were doing a point foot
version of McGeer's walker.
And for the point foot to
work and get this nice swing
without the curved feet,
we had to put a lot of mass
on the upper leg, not
a lot on the lower leg.
So we had these little
fiberglass lower legs
and big heavy upper legs.
And our failure was not
just sort of falling down.
It was exploding the
lower leg into pieces--
[LAUGHTER]
--right, and
completely crashing.
John, you remember that?
Vanessa's walker just kind of--
I'm the one that pushed it, too.
I had a reputation in
lab for a little while.
I had just broken
Rick's airplane.
And I went around
and turned around
and broke Vanessa's walker.
And they're all on tape.
[LAUGHTER]
So McGeer, apart from building
these beautiful machines,
gave us this beautiful
model to think
about the essential
dynamics of walking.
The ballistic walker told
us about the swing phase,
but that's actually
sort of secondary.
What really matters is
this passive interaction
between inertia and
gravity, as Tad said.
And it turns out you can
understand that if you just
think about this little system
called the rimless wheel.
So I'm going to put it on
a slope of angle gamma.
The model is going to be a
simple pendulum with a mass
at the end, but a massless leg.
We'll define theta to be
this, the angle from vertical.
Now, I sort of despise
the fact that my thetas--
I'm not using the
right-hand rule here.
But otherwise, you end
up walking backwards
with negative velocity.
So this is the way it is.
So it's almost like
the simple pendulum
except my coordinate
system's from the top
and theta's sort of reversed.
And in addition to
this simple pendulum,
I've got a few extra legs
that are all massless.
And they're separated by 2
alpha, an angle of 2 alpha.
There's actually
reasonably good pictures
of this, cartoons of
this, in the notes.
So you can think about
this as a bicycle wheel
where somebody took the rim
off and just left the spokes.
So what happens if you
take this bicycle wheel
and you put it at the
top of a small ramp
and you give it a push?
AUDIENCE: It falls over.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It falls over.
OK.
Let's say it's constrained
to be in the plane.
Yeah, that was a fair answer.
So we made an
additional assumption
that it stays upright.
Then what happens?
AUDIENCE: It starts
rolling down.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Starts
rolling down--
OK.
Is it going to roll
faster and faster forever?
AUDIENCE: No.
RUSS TEDRAKE: At
some point, losses
are going to catch up with it.
In the bicycle wheel,
you might think of it
as rolling friction.
In this model,
we're going to do it
by just a bit of impact,
which are very real.
But that's actually
the only thing we need.
We're not going to model
any damping in the system.
So we can really think
about this system as--
let me list all my
assumptions carefully here.
We're going to assume that
the foot, so to speak,
the stance foot is a pin joint.
So I'm going to artificially
assume that that foot doesn't
come off the ground.
As soon as it
catches the ground,
it turns into a pin
joint on the ground.
Instantaneous
transfer for support--
which means, as soon as this leg
comes around, hits the ground,
it becomes the pin joint.
And this guy is free.
I only think about one
ground contact at a time.
I assume that is an
instantaneous transfer support.
The limit of
standing on two legs
is just model that's switching
back and forth really fast
between those two.
And it works out OK.
And then I'm going to
assume that the collisions
with the ground are
inelastic and impulsive.
Impulsive means instantaneous.
Inelastic means that all
energy going into the ground
is lost to the ground.
There's no bouncing.
And I need that, so to make
sure that there's always
exactly one foot on the
ground in this model.
As soon as the thing bounces,
we built rimless wheels
with two wheels.
That way they don't fall down
in practice, just like McGeer's
biped had four legs.
They call it a
four-legged biped.
[LAUGHTER]
But that way you
don't have to worry
about falling over sideways.
And on the real rimless
wheel, you put it on a ramp.
It bounces like crazy.
So this is just a
model, but it actually
captures the essential dynamics.
OK.
So now, you see why it was
good to know everything
we know about pendula.
How is this thing going to work?
I'll show you the
answer real quick.
So here's my rimless wheel.
That was a simulation.
So I'm going to start it.
Every time I hit Go,
it's going to start it
with some random
initial velocity
forward uphill or downhill.
You name it.
That's going up hill,
just enough energy,
turned around and came
back down the hill.
Start speeding up a little bit--
but actually
quickly settles into
a stable forward rolling speed
where the losses from collision
exactly balance
the energy that's
gained from converting
potential to kinetic
as you go down the hill.
That is the essential
idea in walking,
in certainly passive
walking, the conversion
of potential energy and the
balance with dissipation
in the ground.
So this is starting with
a slow initial speed.
And it speeds up a little bit,
goes to that rolling speed.
You started really fast.
It actually slows
down pretty quick
and goes to that
same rolling speed.
Can you see where
I'm going with this?
We've got a stable limit cycle.
It's periodic, clearly.
It's not going to be stable
in the trajectory sense,
but it's going to be stable
in the limit cycle since.
Just I want to see the one
other thing that can happen.
The cool thing about
simulating rimless wheels
is you get all these aliasing
effects and stuff, right?
So if it's going
uphill too fast,
it looks like it's
going downhill.
There you go, uphill, uphill.
OK, see what happens.
Yeah, OK.
So that one just ran out
of energy and stayed still.
That's still my instantaneous
transfer of support.
The simulation is going da, da,
da, da, da, da, changing ground
contacts infinitely fast.
There are serious
simulation people that say
that's the right
way to handle even--
some say that you should
simulate your rigid body--
you should simulate a pin joint
by constantly modeling impacts
at the joints.
This guy Brian Mirtich, who
was at MERL for a while,
did some pretty convincing
work in that world.
So that's the answer
we're going to get.
Now, can we see how that
works on the phase portrait?
If I look at theta and
theta dot, my robot here,
there's a couple key angles.
Theta is only going
to live between--
so it turns out to be gamma
minus alpha and gamma plus
alpha.
See if you can work
that out for yourself.
So this angle is 2 alpha.
When this leg hits
the ground, that angle
has to be alpha plus gamma.
And in the other direction,
it's gamma minus alpha.
Those are the conditions
where this leg
is about to change into a
different coordinate system.
And I forgot to say,
when this foot changes
and it hits the
ground, I quickly
redefine theta to be the theta
around the new pin joint.
I just reset my
coordinate system.
So there's a couple of
key places in this plot.
Somewhere there's
some small gamma,
and that bisects two very
important lines here,
which are theta equals gamma
minus alpha and theta equals
gamma plus alpha.
My coordinate system is 0
around the unstable fixed point.
That's what happened when I
flipped my coordinate system
to the top.
So if I want to superimpose the
phase portrait of the pendulum,
I said 0 is going to be
the unstable fixed point.
So I get the i is
going out this way.
That's the homoclinic
orbits if you remember.
And the smaller orbits
come in and do this.
And the ones up here do this.
Does anybody have the foresight
to sort of jump ahead and tell
me where my limit cycle is going
to live on my picture here?
AUDIENCE: Above.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Above, OK.
What's it going to do?
AUDIENCE: It's going to withdraw
from the same place in each
[INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE:
Awesome, very good.
Yeah, very good.
OK.
So here's everything we just
saw in the rimless wheel.
If I'm rolling fast, if I start
with some initial velocity
rolling fast, say, I'm
high up on this line, then
what happens?
I'm going to ride
this guy over here.
It turns out the
collision model,
I'll tell you the collision
model in a second.
But the inelastic
collision at the base
essentially takes out a fraction
of your velocity at every step.
It's a linear fraction of
your velocity at every step.
So I take my coordinates
over to here.
And then it's going to reset
to a velocity over here,
but with some fraction of
that velocity dissipated.
And I get a new
trajectory like this.
It comes over to
something like this.
And at some point, that
fraction exactly balances.
So because this thing is not
symmetric, when I start here,
I end up a little bit higher
with a little bit more velocity
at the end than when I started.
And I lose a little bit
of velocity in my impact.
And at some point, those
things exactly balance.
And I end up with a stable limit
cycle that looks like that,
right?
What else can happen?
If I start with
too little energy,
the whole thing runs out
of energy and stands still.
What's the critical
energy level?
AUDIENCE: Homoclinic orbit?
RUSS TEDRAKE: The
homoclinic orbit, right?
If I'm just above
the homoclinic orbit,
it actually speeds up and goes
to that same nominal limit
cycle.
But if I'm just below
the homoclinic orbit,
then I never actually make
it across to this thing.
I just end up going,
bonk, over to here.
And then it actually comes in--
if you have to think about it,
trust me--
like this bonk,
like this, and just
ends up running out of
energy and standing still.
AUDIENCE: Could you
start just above it,
but then the collision
knocks it down [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: It depends
on the parameters.
But in the parameter
regime I'm in,
which I think is
the standard one you
want to think about, in order
for it to have some stable--
so basically, what
you're talking about
is a parameter regime where
you have no stable fixed point,
no stable rolling limit cycle.
AUDIENCE: Assuming
your velocity--
RUSS TEDRAKE: If I'm
just epsilon above here
and I go down, then I'm
only going to stand still.
AUDIENCE: If your
collision model
was that you always lose
a particular fraction
of your velocity?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RUSS TEDRAKE: So
in the case where
we have a rolling
fixed point, it
has to be that
epsilon above here
actually gets you
the other thing.
The one maybe you're
thinking about,
too, is that there's
a place over here
where, if I start
with this energy,
I actually come out with
a little less energy.
And I can actually
then go and get
caught in either this
standing fixed point,
or I can transition over
into this fixed point
and go up and get caught.
OK.
There's an easier
way to see all this.
I want you to see it
in the phase portrait
because we thought
a lot about it.
The easier way to see what
all this stuff is by defining
my surface of section and
looking at the Poincaré map.
So let's do that.
Now, in the rimless
wheel, because it
can be going in
either direction,
I'm going to define a little
bit of odd surface of section.
I'm going to define it--
it sure feels like I
got a lot of colors,
but, I don't know, some
sort of red and purple mix.
Let me just make it
really thick here.
Good lord.
Let me define this to be my
surface of section and this
also to be part of my
surface of section.
So any time I have an
impact with the ground,
I'm going to use that
as my return map.
AUDIENCE: So is it just
before or just after?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I do just
after, but it doesn't matter.
As long as you're consistent,
it doesn't matter.
That's a little bit better.
Here's the analytical return
map of the rimless wheel.
I should say the rimless
wheel is the one walking
system that we actually
understand completely.
And I mean, when I talk
about these Poincaré maps,
I can write them
down analytically.
Because I can tell you,
if I'm in this velocity,
where am I going to
end up because I just
have to do a first integral
on the pendulum dynamics.
It's energy conserving.
We're all happy.
So I can tell you everything
about the rimless wheel.
I could tell you about
where it's fixed points lie.
The gray is actually
the basins of attraction
of the fixed points.
I can tell you everything.
There is no other
walking model that I know
of that I can say that about.
This is what you should aspire
to get with all of your walking
machines.
So the red line is
the line of slope 1.
The blue line is the
analytical solution
to the first return map
with the surface of section
defined the way I did.
This is post-collision,
all right?
So it turns out my lines
just got thick enough
that it's a little hard to see,
but there's a blue line here.
It says, if I'm going too
fast, I'm slowing down.
And it'll do its little
staircase right down to this
black fixed point just
above this green line,
which is the rolling fixed
point on the Poincaré map.
This is theta dot at the
n-th step versus theta
dot at the n plus 1-th step.
So there's a
rolling fixed point.
And it's actually stable.
The blue line goes
just above the red line
before it goes down.
There's also a
standing fixed point
with a velocity at 0, which
is the standing on two legs
oscillating back and forth.
That one's stable, too.
And then when you're
rolling backwards uphill,
it always says I'm speeding up.
Every time when I'm
rolling up the hill,
this is negative
initial velocities.
Every time, I'm going to
have a little bit more
forward velocity on every step.
But because this thing
jumps discontinuously
in that staircase fashion, it's
actually a little non-trivial
about whether it's
going to end up
in the rolling fixed point
or the standing fixed point.
Those gray stripes are actually
the basin of attraction
of the rolling fixed point.
So it turns out, if you roll
uphill and you stop with just
enough energy-- you don't
quite get to the top,
and then you roll back down--
then you go into the
other fixed point.
But if you end up at
the top of the hill
pretty much losing
energy like this,
then you're going to stop.
But I can tell you everything
about this return map.
What's the green dashed lines?
The green dashed
lines are places where
my return map are ill-defined.
What could that possibly be?
AUDIENCE: You need balance.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes,
very good, right?
There is some initial
velocity for which I never
return to my return map.
What's that?
It's if I'm on the
homoclinic orbit, right?
It never happens
practice, no big deal.
But there is a set of
measure 0, if you start it
with just the wrong velocity,
it'll go up and sit like this
and never come back.
So those are ill-defined
points in the Poincaré map,
but everything else
we completely know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Sorry.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: We said, like, if you
[INAUDIBLE] a velocity of 0,
then it would stand still there.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why would
there be that line?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh.
Why is there a green line on 0?
AUDIENCE: It's on one stripe.
AUDIENCE: It's a green line
at theta 0, not theta dot 0.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's theta dot 0.
So why do I have to
draw a green line there?
I don't know why I have to
draw a green line there.
I don't remember that
green line being there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, but I don't
think I should have drawn--
I think that's actually
just a MATLAB typo.
There's no reason why
that should be there.
I don't know why that's there.
It's not in the notes.
There's no reason why
that should be there.
I don't know why that's there.
Yeah, John?
AUDIENCE: Homoclinic orbit
doesn't separate the rolling
ones on the right side of the
upper right and the base plot.
Your homoclinic orbit is the
boundary on the left side,
but not on the
right side, right?
This is a--
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's not true.
AUDIENCE: The ones on the right
side roll when they go back.
But they're inside, but they
bounce across to the left.
[INAUDIBLE], right?
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, good.
So there's actually green lines
every fraction of the way.
Is that what you're
asking about?
AUDIENCE: I was actually--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Even the
first one, this one?
AUDIENCE: Because the homoclinic
orbit is not the boundary
or what marks the stable rolling
gates in the [INAUDIBLE] plot,
right?
It is on left side maybe,
but on the right side
you can be inside
the homoclinic orbit.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh,
that's correct.
That's correct.
So I can end up here with
enough energy to transfer over.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Only
here is at the--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's good.
Yes, that's true.
This is the only place where
it's the defining part.
The transition
across from over here
is more complicated,
which is why we end up
with these
trajectories, which get
started up going the other way.
Yeah.
And it's also the case that
there's actually stripes
of these green lines going up.
At every boundary between
the gray and the white,
there's a place where I
could have rolled 10 steps
and ended up balanced
perfectly and then go back.
So I skipped over
the impact dynamics.
The impact dynamics are good
to know, but we can avoid them.
But just to give
you the intuition,
you can define the
energy loss at impact
by just looking at
this rimless wheel
immediately before
the impact here.
And it's got some
momentum that it's
moving along this pin joint.
So it's got to have
some momentum like that.
Immediately after
the collision, it's
going to have a momentum that's
orthogonal to this new pin
joint.
So any energy that's going
into the ground is lost.
So if you model an angular
momentum conservation
around this point, the
angular momentum around this,
which is the component
of this, here remains.
And the other part is lost.
It turns out that,
in the rimless wheel,
you get that as a
simple mapping saying,
theta dot after a collision,
if I use that notation,
turns out to be cosine of 2
alpha times theta dot just
before the collision.
It turns out to be
a trivial mapping.
So you now know the essential
dynamics of walking.
This is actually
most of what you
need to know if you think
about a walking robot.
The dominant source
of energy loss
is not friction in the joints.
So that's pretty small.
I mean, you could make a robot
with friction in the joints.
But the dominant
dynamics of our walking
are dominated by impact at the
ground even for human walking,
right?
So most people think
that the places
you spend the most energy
to recover from the ground
collision are push
off with the toe.
And then you're mostly
passive through.
Ernesto, correct me if
the theories have changed.
You're mostly passive through.
And then there's
one other time where
you spend a lot of energy,
not a lot, but some energy.
We actually decelerate
your leg before knee strike
maybe just to protect your
kneecaps or maybe just
to not walk like
this or something.
I don't know.
But you actually
spend a little bit
of energy doing negative
work to slow down that swing
leg before it collides
with the kneecap.
And that's it.
And the collision
dominates so much
to the point where, if
you want to make an energy
efficient robot,
Andy Ruina says, you
can make it four times more
efficient if you put this push
off just before the collision.
Because if you're coming down
and you suddenly use your push
off to redirect your energy
just before that collision,
you can reduce the
velocity at collision.
And he says that makes a four
time improvement in the energy
efficiency of your robot.
So they've been trying to
build walking robots that
sense the ground just before
by having a little limit switch
sticking down in
front of the foot
and push off right
before ground contact.
That collision dynamics,
what the rimless wheel
tells us about, is the dominant
essential dynamics of walking.
It's the only loss
in the system,
but it's enough to get us
to stable limit cycle out.
The mathematicians like this.
Phil Holmes like this because
he was surprised initially
that and that these piecewise--
this is a energy conserving
system inside each cycle.
It's a piecewise holonomic
system they call it.
And it can have
stable limit cycles.
So people have gone
further than this now.
We can do a little bit
better than a rimless wheel.
If you understand
the rimless wheel
and now you want to
make it a walking robot,
all you have to do is take away
the rigid joined at the hip,
make it a pin joint.
To model the swing
leg dynamics, you
can add some smaller
masses in the leg.
So it's now exactly
the Acrobot dynamics.
You can imagine putting
a torque at the hip.
And that's called the compass
gait model for obvious reasons.
And wouldn't you know it?
If you take a compass gait,
put it on top of a small hill,
give it a push, only
losses come from collisions
with the ground.
Otherwise, it's a, even if
I have no torque at the hip,
passive stance phase.
This thing walks stably
down a small hill.
AUDIENCE: Are you
wanting the legs
to swing free
between [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: Everything
is just 0 torque.
The only trick I'm playing
is that I'm ignoring the foot
scuff here, which, if you
want to build the robot,
you've got to build
a little retracting
toe to make your leg a
little bit shorter when
it goes through.
But, otherwise, you can do this.
And we built these.
Now, this guy has the
rimless wheel actually.
I showed you the
basins of attraction.
The two fixed points, the
rolling and the standing
together, are
globally attractive
except for those
sets of measure 0
where you end up
standing on your toes.
That's not at all true
of the compass gait.
The compass gait's pretty frail.
You have to find
initial conditions that
put it into this walking gait.
I can show you many
simulations of it falling down
catastrophically.
But within some
initial conditions,
you get a nice stable
limit cycle out.
And not surprisingly,
you can go farther.
Put one more set
of links in there.
This is point feet
walking with knees.
We modeled a collision at the
kneecap and with the ground,
but the dynamics are the same.
The limit cycles that
you see in these guys
look a little bit
more appealing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
of the knee [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: It does not
work if the knees have--
you need something that
keeps it a stance leg.
I mean, you might get a
totally different gait out.
But that could be--
AUDIENCE: Well, I meant
just during the swing.
But I guess you have to--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Somehow you have
to end up with a straight leg.
So if it went past
and came back,
if you were exceptionally
lucky in that regard,
you might do it.
But kneecaps are a
good thing, yeah?
You'd feel a little silly
walking down the street
without kneecaps.
So the dynamics of this,
if you sort of project it
onto a single plane, you
get this nice long limit
cycle of the stance leg.
You got an impact,
which instantaneously
decreases your velocity.
Then you get your
stance leg cycle
which is actually basically a
snapshot of your rimless wheel
cycle.
And then you get another
discrete impact which
loses energy on the other side.
And you get this nice limit
cycle for the compass gait.
This is the theta of leg one.
And it's the stance leg here,
and it's the swing leg here.
And trajectories the
neighbor this converge to it
just like you'd expect.
The kneed walker has
another collision
that happens somewhere in
the middle of your swing,
but it all works out.
OK, so I've given
you enough sort of,
I think, to understand the
basic limit cycle dynamics
and the basic stability
property of these things.
Next time, we'll talk a bit
about how you'd actually
apply some of our
previous methods,
for instance, to this now
that we've got a limit cycle
and you've got hybrid
dynamics with these switching
if you want to do things like
compute the gradients to do
optimization.
And so you have to be a little
careful about those impacts
and how they affect things,
but it's not too hard.
And we'll tell you a
bit about the state
of the art and walking control.
They're all sort of
based on this model.
And then Thursday's the midterm.
I promise to have a
practice exam for you.
It might not be
tonight, unfortunately.
But it'll be very soon, tomorrow
or early Saturday morning, I
promise.
Yeah.
OK.
And feel free to ask
me any questions.
Some of you are finding me
to run project ideas by.
That's a great idea.
If you want to talk about
your project, let me know.
Let John know.
See you next time.